When building forms, you've got one main
objective, getting more conversions.
That's when a new visitor to your
site sign up or make a purchase and
nothing is more effective than making
forms quick and easy to finish.
>> Yeah, that makes sense because
the less users have to type,
the less that's in the way
between them and converting.
It's pretty simple.
You know, in my mind the best
example of a super fast form
is Amazon's One Click Ordering.
It's great because you're
just done in milliseconds.
>> True, that's a fast form but
it only works for
some products and
only if the users are already signed in.
For all other situations,
it pay to help out your users.
Guide them through useful labels,
pronged validation, and
progress indicators.
Build their confidence and
watch your conversions go up.
>> That's great advice, let's do it.